et donc les camions rechargeable
passeront à l'électricité c'est bien ça
ok jour 19 de la campagne électorale où
la de souffler des réponses oui alors
bonjour à tous et à toutes
sylvain gaudreault s'y connaît en
environnement alors quand son chef ont
questionné sur le sujet on veut on veut
se libérer du pétrole merci et nous
allons nous battre pour avoir le dernier
mot sur l'environnement oui on me
souffle via la compétence sur les
ressources naturelles
et puis des cloches d'églises viennent
ponctuer une critique de son adversaire
on voit françois legault se transformer
sous nos yeux en jean chrétien
c'est pas très actif pour les
surréalistes a sonné le glas de françois
legault vient de sonner
[Rires]
l'histoire ne dit pas si quelqu'un a
soufflé ce mot d'esprit au chef de la
caq
on échange et max pacioretty ah ouais
mais canadien là-dessus pour un
changement
comme le québec est issue pourrait
charges mal mais il n'est pas allé aussi
loin que sur facebook où il ajoute mieux
vaut tard que jamais ici mathieu prost
radio canada montréal lionel carmant
some specialists un pédo tedo non comme
en europe les doigts parce qu'ils
s'occupent de la tête des enfants
[Musique]